we're in poly Murray college and it's
sunny it's a perfect night you've seen
that first chord
good posture
[Music]
project 14 is a collaboration of the
Glee Club yeah Symphony Orchestra and
the Yale bands which is multiple groups
in itself
[Music]
collaborating together across ensembles
to perform 14 Works within the 14
residential colleges at Yale
[Music]
being back on campus and performing with
my friends and peers was incredibly
cathartic a huge part of playing in
Ensemble is being physically close and
feeling the energy from the people who
are nearest to you
[Music]
to have these performances in the
residential colleges rather than Woolsey
Hall I think makes classical music and
new music much more accessible brings
exposure to people who aren't musicians
[Music]
all the composers are of color there is
a lack of composers of color of works of
color in the classical repertoire or at
least they're not highlighted as much as
they should be I am so excited to
um for this project just to be the the
beginning of repertoire by people of
color by people who are alive
[Music]
I would hope that someone would come up
to me and say like that was so cool I've
never heard anything like that that's
the kind of music that I personally like
to perform things that push the
boundaries of music and what is
culturally acceptable
[Music]